indignation et condamnations dans le
monde entier après la tragédie de
l'avion sud coréen a battu hier par des
chasseurs soviétiques
c'est un acte de terrorisme déclare le
président reagan pour moscou l'appareil
se livrer à des opérations d'espionnage
la situation au tchad offensive libyenne
à l'est du pays selon djamena paris nie
toute intervention de l'aviation
française élections municipales dimanche
à dreux après l'annulation des résultats
de mars un test électoral dominé par le
problème de l'immigration 5 mètre 83
c'est le nouveau record du monde de saut
à la perche établi à rome par le
français thierry vigneron là monsieur
bonsoir l'opprobe l'indignation la
condamnation d'un acte barbare
les réactions de l'opinion et des
gouvernements sont unanimes dans le
monde l'a en tout cas où l'information
circule 269 personnes sont mortes hier
en plein ciel pulvérisée par un missile
lancé par un chasseur soviétique
au bout de deux heures et demie de
traque au dessus de l'espace aérien
soviétique depuis hier dix gardes côtes
japonais et deux avions américains
s'efforcent de repérer en mer des traces
du boeing 747
mais les autorités soviétiques n'ont pas
autorisé les bâtiments japonais a
pénétré dans leurs eaux territoriales
pour repêcher d'éventuels survivants oui
nous le dreff
une liste de noms affichés comme un
martyrologe par la compagnie coréenne
269 non 269 personnes désintégré en
plein ciel 269 paisible voyageurs dans
un avion aux couleurs d'une compagnie
aérienne civile
mondialement connu abattu froidement par
les soviétiques
trois missiles qui ont transformé la
quiétude d'un vol sans histoire en
horreur pure au sud de sakhaline ses
produits l'inimaginable d'asie ou
d'amérique 1000 appels angoissés
interroge le siège de la compagnie
aérienne avec encore la folle espérance
d'un miracle et c'est la certitude du
drame et l'abattement la douleur des
familles devient celle d'un pays tout
entier la corée du sud est et proclame
le deuil national et puis les
témoignages
ce pêcheur japonais au large de
sakhaline a vu une lueur dans le ciel et
a entendu trois explosions
le japon a envoyé des navires jusqu'à la
limite extrême des eaux internationales
pas dans l'espoir de trouver des
survivants certes on cherche des épaves
des traces matérielles mais pas question
de s'approcher davantage de sakhaline
les japonais dès hier après-midi vous le
savez washington révélée par la bouche
du secrétaire d'état américain george
shultz le déroulement de la tragédie
la version des faits ainsi exposé hier
n'a pas été infirmée jusqu'ici un
mystère demeure l'absence de tout
enregistrement radio de l'avion coréen
qui pourrait être dû à une panne
généralisée en tout cas derrière soi
washington exigeait de moscou une
explication au monde et demandait la
réunion urgente du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies qui vient de commencer
ce soir à huis clos
il n'y a pas d'explication à cet acte de
barbarie a répété ce matin le secrétaire
d'état américain et le président reagan
écourtant ses vacances en californie est
rentré cet après midi
à washington il doit ce soir consulter
son conseil national de sécurité
dès son arrivée devant les journalistes
réunis à la maison blanche où l'on
rappelle qu'il y avait au moins 30
américains à bord de l'appareil dont un
parlementaire le président reagan a en
termes extrêmement sévère accusé l'union
soviétique
il s'en est pris à la nature n'est lors
de ces quatre mois à moscou l'agencé
tass dans un communiqué de 22 ling s'est
d'abord contenté de répéter que bière
qu'un incident aérien avait bien eu lieu
qu'un avion a connu avait violé par deux
fois l'espace aérien soviétique que la
chasse soviétique avait vainement tenté
de l'intercepter avant qu'il ne continue
son vol vers la mer du japon sans jamais
faire état du sort de l'appareil ni de
ses passagers et puis il ya moins d'une
heure le kremlin par le biais de l'agent
seince livrer ses propres explications
sans démentir les informations selon
lesquelles son aviation avait abattu
l'appareil
le boeing sud coréen selon l'agent stas
se livrer à des opérations de
renseignement
jusqu'ici le pignon soviétique ne savait
rien de la tragédie hier
ce soir le journal de la télévision
soviétique en a fait mention
m
oui ça va apporter vos voisins toujours
démenti peut-être qu'ils explosent et il
est enfin selon lesquelles le boeing 747
de la compagnie sud-coréenne
on va tâcher a bâti dans la salle c'est
éthique au dessus de l'île de sakhaline
dans une déclaration un petit homme que
l'avion s'est enfoncé dans les trains
c'est rien c'est décider quelle
profondeur de 500 kg net et nous restons
répondu opinions des décès un newbie
beaucoup de secondes mais d'anticiper
l'espace arias est explicite en
direction de la mer du japon est à
distinguer des gradins affirme avancer
notre attention davantage tomber des
accusations sont les états unis la
taille de la cale auraient été envoyés à
des fins haut de ses 17 ans étaient six
à des fins d'espionnage un diktat et par
l'office de provocation c'est donc en
ces termes que l'opinion soviétique ce
soit a été enfin informé de la tragédie
liait la corée du sud dont les relations
avec moscou ont toujours été très
tendues les deux pays n'entretiennent
d'ailleurs pas de relations
diplomatiques la corée du sud a demandé
à l'urss des excuses formelles le
châtiment des responsables et un
dédommagement à séoul les autorités
affirment qu'elle ignore toujours
pourquoi et comment l'appareil des
lignes coréenne n'a pas suivi sa route
régulière une route qui suis l'un des
cinq couloirs de survol autorisé
au-dessus du territoire soviétique mais
qui était la plus proche de la zone
stratégique la plus secrète du
dispositif militaire soviétique l'île de
sakhaline
patrick esther en voyages aériens
la ligne droite n'est jamais le plus
court chemin ainsi pour passer de new
york à tokyo
les avions de vignes raccourcissent de
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres leur
chemin en passant par le pôle nord
c'est la route dans corps edge un
couloir aérien particulièrement
réglementée
coincé entre l'alaska américaine et
l'union soviétique
paris et qui se rendent au japon par par
la voie du pôle donc par encore lg qui
suivent cette route tous les jours et il
n'est pas impossible
les erreurs peuvent arriver
ce sont des hommes qui pilote les
haillan et on peut très bien concevoir
qu'un jour un avion de la france subisse
le même sort du moins en ce qui concerne
la sortie de la sortie de sa route j'ai
posé une question s'il se passe un
incident comme ça vous avez les
consignes qu'est ce que vous devez faire
et nous devons prévenir immédiatement le
contrôle le contrôle avec lequel nous
sommes en taxes à lire les américains ou
les japonais un peu plus loin et nous
devons rejoindre la route le plus vite
possible
voilà les consignes que nous avons on
peut voir quelles sont contradictoires
avec le bien sûr si nous sommes
intercepté par des militaires la
première des consignes supplée
militaires des militaires ce n'est pas
ce qui manque ici les bases nucléaires
et stratégiques foisonnent à l'ouest
comme à l'est
ainsi en redescendant les avions de
ligne passe-t-il très près de base ultra
secrète comme celle de petropavlovsk où
se trouve le port d'attache de sous
marins nucléaires
ce centre est aussi chargé d'analyser la
précision des tirs d'essai des missiles
nucléaires soviétiques
c'est dire son importance un peu plus au
sud
toute la côte de sakhaline est occupé
par des terrains d'aviation
c'est de cette île qui a décollé
avant-hier l'escadrille de soukhoï 15 un
ancien modèle de chasseur soviétique des
années 60 qui a abattu
d'après les américains les voiliers 747
sud coréen avec probablement un missile
comme celui vous allez voir d'après les
japonais ce soir le responsable serait
bel et bien un mig-23 la politique est
ouvert plus à l'ouest
joe braun ni l'un des plus grands champs
de missiles ss 11 tourner vers les états
unis
cette base est maîtresse dans la
stratégie militaire de l'urss
non loin de là khabarovsk la base d'où
partent les bombardiers nucléaire
backfire à long rayon d'action d'etupes
oleffe ultra secret dont les photos sont
très difficiles à trouver
enfin à 800km bladi vostok port
d'attache de la plus grosse des quatre
flotte soviétique celle du pacifique
presque chaque semaine les contrôleurs
aériens japonais enregistre des passages
de mick soviétique dans leur espace
aérien
sous notre surveillance électronique
dans cette région du monde
rien ne peut passer inaperçue et
pourtant il est bien difficile de savoir
exactement ce qui s'y est passé
il y à 48 heures quelle que soit la
difficulté à vérifier l'exactitude des
accusations soviétique quant à la
mission d'espionnage conduite par un
boeing 747 d'une ligne d'aviation civile
même coréenne les relations est-ouest se
sont sérieusement tendus depuis hier
washington a donc réagi très durement en
tout cas dans son langage
reste à voir en termes plus concrets
quelle va être la nature de la riposte
américaine
monsieur hartmann vous êtes en ce moment
à washington mais vous êtes
l'ambassadeur américain à moscou alors
une première information est ce que
votre secrétaire d'état george schultz a
toujours l'intention de rencontrer son
homologue soviétique andreï gromyko à
madrid la semaine prochaine comme prévu
oui je crois que ce soit notre passé
notre secrétaire d'état va rencontrer
notre président pour discuter une
appréciation assez profonde de toute
cette situation mais il a exprimé son
intention de procéder à nantes reid de
parler avec ministre que m
économique et de dire face à face
non non
point de vue d'homme les termes plus
trop le plus fort alors le président
oregan qui est donc arrivé tout à
l'heure à washington a obtenu on viens
de l'entendre un langage extrêmement dur
à l'égard de moscou est ce que
concrètement on peut s'attendre à des
mesures de rétorsion par exemple
l'annulation du dernier contrat de
livraisons de blé donc je crois que le
choses le plus important de garder en
vue pour le moment c'est c'est pas un
problème entre les états unis et l'union
soviétique
c'est un problème entre le monde entière
et l'union soviétique et l'indignation
je crois qu'ils étaient ailleurs exprimé
hier soir partout les nations civilisées
battre
comm réd communiqué camille de quai à
l'union soviétique
alors cette sorte de deux conduits ne
peut pas peut être acceptée alors
j'apprends à l'instant que le
département d'état rejette la nouvelle
version des faits offert par l'agencé
tass oui nous avons vu les
communications et il y avait les actions
que nous avons est décrit hier et nous
avons la preuve
et aussi je crois qu'il ya dans cette
situation la preuve qu'il faut et les
moyens nationale pour vérifier tous les
tous les accords de entre nous et par
exemple d'avoir la possibilité de voir
quelles sont les situations surtout dans
la région à côté de l'union soviétique
alors sur le plan diplomatique il faut
bien dire que la tragédie peut présenter
certains avantages pour washington au
moment où moscou mène en europe surtout
une sérieuse offensive psychologiques
liés au déploiement des euromissiles je
crois pour tout le monde
pour moi personnellement il y avait
toujours deux situations que nous sommes
entre entre les états unis et l'union
soviétique il ya les systèmes tout à
fait différent nous sommes les
adversaires il ya les raisons pour
laquelle nous sommes les adversaires
nous avons un ebit tout à fait différent
entre nous et entre l'ouest en général
et l'union soviétique et il faut garder
cette situation en vue et pour moi
personnellement le choses le plus
intéressant pour tout le monde
maintenant c'est de garder les unités
devoir de mettre le l'union soviétique
le gouvernement devant ses
responsabilités et de demande les
explications alors justement monsieur
l'ambassadeur une dernière question vous
connaissez bien les rouages du système
soviétique puisque c'est votre fonction
quelle est selon vous la la réponse la
plus probable à la question la plus
grave est ce que oui ou non le kremlin a
donné l'ordre d'abattre l'avion coréen
je n'avais pas les précisions à offrir à
ce sujet il y avait deux heures et demie
de suite' par le radar russe et pendant
cette période je suis sûr qu'ils avaient
les communications entre l'avion et les
contrôleurs et surtout avec les
autorités plus haut je ne peux parler
dire si les autorités le plus haut c'est
à dire les autos étaient politiques ont
donné l'ordre aux 7
action affreux monsieur l'ambassadeur je
vous remercie
en effet entre tous les scénarios
possibles
la question centrale est bien celle à
georges bortoli qui a donné l'ordre de
tirer il ya deux hypothèses alors
théoriquement les autorités militaires
soviétiques peut pratiquer une certaine
délégation de pouvoir il est
théoriquement possible que la décision
de tirer étaient prises à l'échelon du
commandement de région militaire
c'est-à-dire depuis vladivostok
c'est la première hypothèse décisions
locales ce qui pourrait expliquer
l'incroyable rigidité de cette décision
parce que le général local a dû se
conformer à des règlements très très
très précis les appliquer à la lettre
n'est ce pas avec une espèce de
d'hystérie bureaucratique la viande
aurait pu elle ne répond pas il n'obéit
pas bon et bien boum on tire si vous
laissez courteline revue par kafka ou
par un scénariste de films d'horreur il
ya aussi une autre hypothèse
soyez notre hypothèse parce que comme le
disait monsieur hartmann un instant il
ya eu de même plus de deux heures entre
le moment où l'avion ont été repérés par
les soviétiques et le moment où le
pilote a tiré
donc il est très possible que le général
local concerné ce soit rouvert en
appelant moscou et à ce moment là on a
eu à prendre la décision un échelon
différents l'échelon des généraux très
galonnés des têtes pensantes de l'armée
et des généraux qui sont déjà un petit
peu politique alors qu'est ce qu'on
pense chez généraux politique soviétique
on pense peut-être me semble utile que
monsieur rendre au port a été un petit
peu loin en annonçant qu'il détruirait
qu'il titre urech certains missiles
quelques dizaines de soldats soviétiques
pour essayer de reprendre la négociation
avec les états unis d'où crispation doux
tentative de se montrer énergique de
montrer qu'on n'a pas peur des états
unis ça c'est le deuxième scénario celui
qui a fait ça aurait une tête politique
qu'il aurait pensé qu'il ne fallait pas
hésiter le cas échéant à torpiller un
petit peu disons les initiatives de paix
de monsieur en drop et un scénario qui
dans ses hypothèses là aurait
parfaitement bien réussi à passer leurs
armes nous ont abondamment prouvé à quel
point ça réussit tentative de reprise du
dialogue
russo américain les tentatives qui était
évident depuis quelques semaines bon
c'est torpiller et puis cette magnifique
explosion de pacifisme en allemagne
fédérale qui perd de son sens et de sa
crédibilité et qui était pourtant bien
utile à la diplomatie soviétique dans
tous les pays occidentaux les
gouvernements demandent des explications
aux ambassadeurs soviétique
c'est le cas du gouvernement français
qui dès hier soit exprimé sa vive
indignation l'ambassade soviétique à
paris a protesté ce matin contre ce
qu'elle appelle la campagne anti
soviétique hystérique menée en france
depuis hier mais la visite du ministre
soviétique des affaires étrangères à
paris lundi et mardi prochain est
maintenue
la france réagit donc de manière nuancée
même si déjà certains hommes politiques
et certains intellectuels demande
l'annulation ou le report de la visite
pas de réaction officielle du parti
communiste français à propos de la
tragédie
ce matin pierre juquin s'est déclaré ému
et à ferloo qui toutes les personnalités
politiques françaises expriment leur
indignation comme le font à l'unisson
les capitales occidentales et le pape
jean paul ii qu'il s'est déclarée
bouleversée
bouleversée c'est le mot juste car au
delà de toutes les considérations
politiques de toutes les analyses
nécessaires pour comprendre les
conséquences de la tragédie
il faut paul lefèvre repenser aux
victimes
oui parce que criminels de guerre ou
criminelles de paix un homme peut-il
dormir ce soir peut être le pilote du
score peut-être le général commandant la
région de vladivostok peut-être le
maréchal ministre dimitri ustinov
peut-être même youri andropov qu'importe
269 êtres humains qui aujourd'hui n'ont
plus à se poser la question des femmes
des enfants des hommes dorment en lisant
certains avaient au départ peut être un
peu peur de l'avion d'autres
connaissances ou de se sentir rassuré un
peu depuis le décollage tous voulaient
plus ou moins consciemment le fait tout
dans ces cas-là oublier la mer froide
l'inconnu sombre l'eau profonde au
dessous de très loin et puis le ronron
un peu assourdissant le bruit rassurants
des réacteurs géants que l'oreille
surveille alors même qu'on se dit
rassuré vous savez 269 des noms sur une
liste anonyme
quelques-uns des millions de passagers
coq le quotidien 269 que personne
d'entre nous ne connaissaient et que
demain nous allons
oublié il fait un peu beau aussi un
impôt nouveau et ordonné 269 sacrifier
actifs pourquoi victimes de guerre ou
victimes de paix une question qui agite
particulièrement les pacifistes ouest
allemand qui vous le savez hier ont
commencé leur grande offensive d'automne
en prévision du déploiement des
euromissiles si les négociations de
genève échoue michel meyer a reconnu
aujourd'hui à bonn a recueilli
aujourd'hui à bonn leurs réactions
nous les verts nous considérons
l'abattement de l'avion sud-coréen
d'être une violation des lois
internationales et un acte et inhumain
et franchement dit une action criminelle
est inexcusable et c'est un mauvais coup
pour notre mouvement de paix nous sommes
réalistes et nous avons aucune illusion
de la vraie nature de la nature
véritable de l'union soviétique de la
système politique
il est connu que nous soutenons le
mouvement de paix à l'est aussi mais
dans le contexte de la discussion
actuelle il est nécessaire de cet été
soulignée avec les peurs chine 2 on ne
fera que renforcer les faucons à moscou
voilà donc tour d'horizon très vaste
vous l'avez constaté le tour d'horizon
auquel on pouvait procéder ce soir pour
tenter d'analyser de peser les
conséquences de la tragédie du boeing
747 de l'aviation sud coréenne au tchad
pour la première fois depuis un mois les
combats ont repris sur le terrain les
forces de goukouni oueddei soutenu par
la libye ont tenté un mouvement offensif
dans la région d'oum chalhoub à dans
l'est du pays
mais contrairement à ce qu'affirmait le
quartier général de goukouni à tripoli
il n'y a pas eu d'intervention armée
française les jaguars ont simplement
effectuer une mission d'entraînement
sentir précise le ministère de la
défense
paul nahon la ville d'oum chalhoub à se
trouve au nord-est du pays à 600 km de
la capitale djamena et si l'on en croit
le président hissène habré les troupes
libyennes ont attaqué cette localité
avec des chars de l'artillerie lourde et
des véhicules blindés mais sans faire
appel à l'aviation
cependant chiffres cités 3000 fantassins
libyens auraient été engagés dans cette
bataille
une précision importante cette ville
d'une chaloupe à est situé à plus de 80
kilomètres du poste français le plus au
nord donc aucun soldat français chargé
de défendre le périmètre de sécurité
n'aurait été engagés dans les combats
il semble donc bien que cette attaque si
elle a eu lieu met fin à la trêve tacite
qui durait depuis plusieurs jours entre
tripoli et djamena d'autre part d'après
tripoli les avions jaguar serait
intervenu pour bombarder la région dont
celle où bas
le ministère français de la défense
affirme lui qu'aucun jaguar n'a tiré
enfin et ce n'est pas une coïncidence
cette attaque libyennes auraient été
déclenchés le jour même où le colonel
kadhafi célébraient à tripoli le 14e
anniversaire de son arrivée au pouvoir
devant son armée au grand complet il a
dénoncé le grand satan américain et les
visées impérialistes en afrique et au
liban israël nouveau premier ministre
itzhak shamir 61 68 ans l'ancien
ministre des affaires étrangères dans le
cabinet begin a obtenu hier dans la nuit
l'aval de son parti et il a obtenu
aujourd'hui l'appui des autres membres
de la coalition gouvernementale à
beyrouth levée partielle du couvre-feu
aujourd'hui mais la population de la
partie chrétienne de la ville à observer
une grève générale pour protester contre
le massacre d'une trentaine de
villageois maronites dans la montagne
massacres perpétrés selon toute
vraisemblance par les milices russe de
walid joumblatt la politique française
maintenant avec les propos du premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste lionel
jospin qui était toute à l'heure
l'invité d'antenne de midi l'opinion
française a dit monsieur jospin a bien
compris que nous sommes dans une crise
profonde et que nous devons être à la
hauteur des enjeux
lionel jospin a appelé la gauche à faire
preuve de réalisme et il a reproché à
raymond barre d'avoir parlé de déroute
intellectuelle de la gauche alors que je
cite monsieur n'ose pas monsieur bart a
laissé faire la déroute de l'industrie
et organiser la déroute de la recherche
fin de citation à propos du prochain
congrès du parti socialiste lionel
jospin a souhaité que ce soit un congrès
d'ouverture de dynamisme et de
rassemblement le sondage mensuel figaro
magazine sur la cote de popularité du
chef de l'état et de son premier
ministre trois points de plus pour
monsieur mitterrand deux points de plus
pour monsieur mauroy premier test
électoral de la rentrée dimanche à dreux
les élections municipales de mars
dernier avait été annulé par le tribunal
istres hâtif la campagne électorale de
ces derniers jours a été dominée par le
thème qui avait déjà durci la campagne
du mois de mars celui de l'immigration
pyrale les vacances ont sans doute
permis de calmer les passions qui avait
agité dreux il ya six mois
mais dans cette ville ouvrière où le
chômage est durement ressentie où près
d'un habitant sur quatre est de souche
étrangère
les derniers jours de campagne
électorale ont vu resurgir la trilogie
immigration insécurité chômage dans un
climat tendu
pourtant le paysage politique lui a
changé à gauche d'abord l'ancien maire
françoise gaspard qui avait démissionné
en mars par souci de décrispation n'est
plus tête de liste à sa place un homme
neuf
marcel piquer un chef d'entreprise aux
allures débonnaires qui prêche la
tolérance et parle avec le coeur nous ne
pouvons pas renvoyer dans leur pays des
gens que nous avons fait venir il y a
quinze ans il ya vingt ans qui ont leurs
enfants scolarisés dans les écoles dont
beaucoup d'entre eux ne parlent que le
français
il serait aussi étrangers dans leur pays
d'origine que dans notre propre pays et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui s'il y a des
circonstances économiques difficiles
pour tous
nous devons avant tout être avoir le
respect
d'êtres humains qui ont les mêmes
problèmes que nous l'opposition
également à changer de leader
impossible en mars à cause de l'alliance
rpa front national l'union rpr udf s'est
fait cette fois derrière jean hieaux un
banquier gaulliste qui se veut contre
tous les extrémismes n'exclut pas
cependant une alliance avec l'extrême
droite au second tour
j'ai toujours dit et je ne change pas
que si l'alliance est nécessaire au
second tour pour battre la gauche qui
conduisent selon moi une politique très
mauvaises pour la france et politique
soutenue par monsieur piqué si cette
alliance était nécessaire je la ferai
j'ai toujours a ajouté je ne serai pas
l'otage de quiconque fusent de monsieur
stirbois et que le bulldozer de la
mairie n'y aura pas détruire et logement
d'immigrés comme ça se fait dans la
région parisienne reste celui par qui le
scandale est arrivé
aux yeux de la gauche et des immigrés en
tout cas jean pierre stirbois dit ce
qu'il pense il faut régler le problème
des immigrés avant qu'il soit trop tard
son score de 12 et demi pour cent aux
dernières cantonales lui permet de
penser qu'il faudra compter avec lui ce
qui fait ma force je crois c'est que
j'apparais aujourd'hui à dreux en tout
cas comme celui qui dit tout haut ce que
la majorité des droits pensent tout bas
et je pense qu'un si je vais pouvoir
catalyser les voies du ras-le-bol et
voir venir un mois des électeurs qui
votent traditionnellement autant pour le
parti communiste pour le parti
socialiste que pour l'udf et le rpr
c'est ça une des caractéristiques et ses
sages orban qui demain va créer la
surprise de 4 septembre
surprise ou pas on verra en attendant le
verdict des deux roues et les candidats
et leurs équipes n'ont pas ménagé leurs
efforts
la ville ya sans doute perdu un peu de
propreté la campagne aussi le conseil
d'état a confirmé aujourd'hui
l'annulation des élections municipales
de sarcelles est en revanche validé
celle de choisy-le-roi production
toujours bloquée aujourd'hui à l'usiné
citroën d'aulnay
une grève bouchon a lieu dans un atelier
de ferrage le prix des carburants va
changer le 12 septembre vous le savez le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
vient de préciser que le litre de super
augmentera de 3 centimes et l'ordinaire
de 4 centimes le gazole va baisser de
deux centimes et le fioul domestique de
2,3 sans fil
place au sport maintenant est d'abord au
tennis à flushing meadow yannick noah va
discuter cette nuit son deuxième tour
contre un autre français jérôme vanier
non on n'est pas au mieux semble-t-il
son genou le fait encore souffrir son
entraîneur patrice âge de lower a même
précisé que nos avait failli abandonner
lors de son match contre scott davis
mardi au cours de ce deuxième tour
l'espagnole iberia de série numéro 10 a
été éliminé par le britannique john
lloyd en trois sets et guillermo vilas
s'est difficilement qualifié pour le
troisième tour il a battu l'américain en
cinq sets et 3h40 de mac
le saut à la perche décidément ans -
iliad en jeu plus les perchistes
français soto en effet moins d'une
semaine après les 5 mètres 82e réalisé
par pierre quinon à cologne qui rit
vigneron a établi hier à rome un nouveau
record du monde de saut à la perche avec
5 mètre 83 vigneron avait terminé 8e du
concours lors des championnats du monde
d link qui rend jézabel
71 ans après les 4 mètres 0-2 de
l'américain wright quatre jours après
les 4 m 82 de pierre quinon est pour la
troisième fois de sa carrière thierry
vigneron bat le record du monde de saut
à la perche
en 1981 thierry vigneron est le premier
à franchir 5 mètre 75 en 1980 le premier
à passer la barre des 5 mètres 80 à 23
ans il a toujours été considéré comme le
plus doué des perchistes français
malheureusement comme les autres thierry
vigneron a toujours déçu au moment des
grands rendez vous septième à moscou
avec cinq mètres 45 8e a ici qui avec 5
mètres 40 seulement
mais lorsque le poids des
responsabilités ne baisse pas thierry
vigneron c'est l'homme qui monte et a
remis le montrent encore pu 5 mètre 83
notre confrère italien la gazzetta dello
sport titre ce matin vignerons sur le
toit du monde sur le toit peut-être pas
mais presque
5 83 ça fait très exactement cet auteur
c'est à dire un petit peu moins de 2 et
passe d'un immeuble ancien avec un peu
de chance au prochain record on arrivera
au troisième étage c'est à dire au
balcon du dessus il y aura un tiercé
demain à vincennes dans le grand prix
des ardennes les pronostics de pierre de
bresse le 19 le 17 le 18 le dise le 3 le
14 le 15 et le 16 c'est la fête au
château de versailles ce soir en
présence du ministre des relations
extérieures claude cheysson des
représentants américains et britanniques
on célèbre le bicentenaire des traités
de paris et de versailles qui ont scellé
l'indépendance des états unis
un anniversaire qui a fait l'objet de
répétition en grande pompe et en
costumes jean marie dubois
rappelez vous vos le fond d'histoire
1780 les américains avec l'aide des
français commandé par le lieutenant
général rochambeau écrase les anglais à
la bataille de yorktown 3 septembre 1783
le traité signé à versailles marque
l'indépendance des états unis d'amérique
et bien c'est pour fêter ces deux
événements que 500 américain en costumes
d'époque ont défilé dans les rues devant
dos la capitale de rochambeau même une
femme étaient présents les américains
passionnés de leur histoire connaissent
mieux que nous toutes les subtilités du
costume militaire français
soissons gaulle tél
cela monsieur c'est un bouton qui
indique le numéro du régiment et cela
que nous sommes allés très loin
combattre tout est reconstitué dans les
moindres détails régime en costumes et
musique mais hier la répétition générale
on prépare la grande parade qui se
déroulera ce soir à l'endroit même où
fut signé le traité de versailles alain
gillot-pétré qui n'est pas un costume
d'époque malheureusement va nous parler
du temps suis encore en costume d'été
mais je vous offre l'automne en
avant-première regarder pourquoi sur la
photo satellite avec une superbe superbe
dépression regarder elle est magnifique
elle était centrée au large de l'irlande
elle a soufflé à plus de 100 kilomètres
heure sur les côtes bretonnes 80 km
heure à paris c'était à 14 heures elle
s'enfonce elle est passée sur le centre
du pays elle s'enfonce progressivement
vers le sud est et nous aurons ce temps
si demain donc un temps extrêmement
instable regarder la carte maintenant
dans l'ensemble ces variables sur toute
la france avec des averses
averses plus fréquentes du nord de la
seine au nord des alpes
mais des averses ou si ailleurs ça se
calmera sur l'atlantique où les
éclaircies deviendront plus importante
dans l'après-midi le mistral va se lever
et il fera beau sur la méditerranée
après que le mauvais temps sera passé le
matin j'allais oublié de vous dire qu'il
y aura également encore des rafales de
vent d'ouest assez forte sur les côtes
de la manche et le baromètre est en
hausse
normal nous sommes passés derrière le
front froid les températures en revanche
c'est vraiment l'automne 15° à brest 15
9 et bresse 17 cherbourg 17 rouen 17
rennes 17 limoges 19 biarritz 20 paris
ça n'est vraiment pas beaucoup maximum
prévu 28 degrés à bastia demain samedi 3
septembre trois minutes de soleil en
moins élevés 7h10 coucher 20h29 c'est la
saint grégoire est aussi la fête de
saint row de gang
quel patron début
on y travaille 23h05 claude sérillon
vous présentera notre dernier journal
demain à 12h45 vous avez rendez vous
avec noël mamère et à 20h avec bernard
rapp
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
lundi très bonne soirée